foreign
has a question for us how do you
maintain a minimalist lifestyle when it
turns from months into years what tools
do you use to not spend or purchase when
the temptation to fill a void eventually
creeps back up again I want you to
understand something right away the void
that you are experiencing right now
cannot be filled because it is not a
void hmm
it's open space
when Ryan and I lived in Montana we
didn't go up to Glacier National Park
and say look at this void can we get
some condos in here immediately
of course not there's beautiful open
space and instead of saying how do we
fill this void we say what do we do with
this open space the void you're
experiencing right now has been
propagated by corporations marketers
advertisers to make you feel inadequate
or incomplete
to make you think the open space that
you have the freedom that you have is
wrong it is not wrong now that said I
have something practical for you as well
Ryan and I have the the 30 30 rule that
we came up with we also call it the wait
for it rule if you want to buy something
here's my rule in my own life if it
costs 30 or more
I'm gonna wait 30 hours to buy it why is
that I can afford to buy a 30 thing
right but quite often if I give myself
enough distance between the impulse and
the purchase
well I don't make the impulse purchase
ever because it's now an informed
purchase
it's never an impulse purchase I never
impulse purchase anymore if I wait 30
hours to buy a thing if I still feel
compelled to buy it and I still think it
will add value I've still contemplated
it over those 30 hours if I've waited a
day basically then I will still buy it
but no longer am I driven by impulse I'm
driven by necessity by value and that's
what purchasing things is all about well
this enhance my life well it augment my
life will it amplify my life will it
magnify this aspect of my life if so
wonderful let's bring it in by the way
if it costs more than a hundred dollars
I try to wait 30 days now that doesn't
always work but what I'll tell you is
that it's enabled me to forget about so
many potential impulse purchases I'll
even put it in my cart and I wait till
the next day I say why the hell is this
still in my car just go in there and
delete it and move on yeah yeah
for me temptation is an attractive
opportunity to meet a healthy need in an
unhealthy way and when you're struggling
with some kind of Temptation it's so
important to not condemn yourself for
having the need or for feeling tempted
to do things that might fulfill that
need that's a natural normal healthy
thing the problem however is these
Temptations are in some ways a
compromise on our dignity or they are
self-destructive or they compromise
long-term priorities that we might have
and so we find ourselves being attached
or addicted to these things that don't
serve us and when we condemn the need
and say oh I'm so bad for even having
that Temptation I'm so bad for wanting
to be loved wanting to be seen wanting
to have company wanting to be
appreciated and then you try to suppress
the Temptation or you try to not do the
thing that's unhealthy what happens is
you can turn away from it for a while
but then the reality of that need crops
back up and then you say oh but I gotta
suppress the need I can't do it and then
you give back into the Temptation and
there's just this unhealthy cycle of
beating yourself up and suppressing your
desires and trying to exercise
discipline to not do this darn thing and
what you have to do is step back and say
what legitimate healthy need is this
temptation fulfilling for me and what
does a healthy approach to meeting that
need look like and then it ceases to be
this winless game of stop doing that
unhealthy thing and it becomes this
life-giving process of I'm going to
start doing this healthy robust
life-giving thing and even though it's
going to be hard as heck at first to
rewire my brain and restructure my
habits after a while I'm gonna be so
glad I started this new routine I'm
gonna be so glad I broke free from those
old addictions because when I do it the
healthy way it's gonna feel so much
better and it's Gonna Keep Me free from
all of those other energies in my life
that were eating away at my peace and my
happiness my joy my relationships and so
on man I feel like you just relieved a
bunch of people of guilt from the
desires that they have I love what you
said like it's a healthy desire it's
just dealing with it in an unhealthy way
that's powerful man
um
man uh what was the question again oh
yeah Temptation I just use a 30 30 day
rule uh the other the other day
um uh like a few days ago I was on a
hike with Beulah and Alex and their
friend Seth Mariah and I were and Buell
had this like phone case I was like
that's a I've never looked at the phone
case I've been like oh wow that's like
very aesthetically pleasing
um and uh she told me what it was and I
was like oh I'm gonna get that I'm like
I'm gonna wait a little bit and I did
um I ended up getting it but I did I did
so intentionally it wasn't like this
impulse
um and it was even more tempting because
it was on sale it was like you know
Cyber Monday I don't know what it was
but it was some kind of you know holiday
special type thing so it made it even
more justifiable
um when uh when I went to like look at
it but but yeah I mean these rules just
creates a little bit of friction enough
friction to
um
yeah to help you make more deliberate
decisions the one thing I want to say
about the void though
is so for me there's a little bit of a
void that I feel
and what I've learned to do
is kind of make friends with it like
that void is their
uh to motivate me to inspire me to like
to guide me in a way that's kind of how
I look at it and I love what you talk
about as viewing it as open space Josh
that's how you make friends with that's
how you make friends with it yeah that's
one way you can you can do that did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free